buenos días damas y caballeros el
comandante observen que en este avión en
cuatro salidas de emergencia dos puertas
situadas sobre
[Música]
la indicación de preocupación del
jugador su vuelo
[Música]
a hacer como un cruce
sobre la danza y sobre como la danza
y el cuerpo que habitamos corresponde
también al territorio que habitamos y
cómo podemos con movernos con vivir
juntos a través de la danza entonces eso
fue la dirección que tome y por eso hay
10 capítulos que cuentan una historia
que no es tradicional porque el
coreógrafo le vemos 13 segundos al final
completamente de la película pero toda
la película presenta su trabajo sus
coreografías y está su inversión activa
en su perspectiva que corresponde en
varios aspectos con la mía
[Música]
dios pérez en esa sesión
hola por es interesting estuvo el que me
subí vitrinas
ah
hija sharon place
entonces
la música de en el descanso y
seguramente
[Música]
pero cuál es su relación beatriz con la
danza porque usted dice es la
perspectiva del coreógrafo y la
perspectiva mía como cineasta pero su
relación personal con este arte cuál es
pues para mí es un arte bastante
fundamental que todos hacemos sin darnos
cuenta la primera cosa yo pienso incluso
en cuando en el útero de la madre ya
empezamos a movernos ya tener conciencia
de lo que estamos habitando nuestro
cuerpo
y para mí la danza permite al cuerpo de
hablar
y pienso que el cuerpo es mucho más
inteligente que lo que pensamos muchas
veces la gente dice el cuerpo y el
espíritu o el cuerpo y la mente como dos
cosas separadas para mí es lo mismo
el cuerpo y es más fácil yo pienso
mentir con la palabra que con el cuerpo
el cuerpo puede mentir más difícilmente
cuando se mueve del espacio cuando si
por ejemplo tengo me da un susto pues el
cuerpo reacciona me manda diferentes
productos químicos que el mismo produce
y me duele la tripa o tengo calor tengo
frío si pienso en algo feliz el cuerpo
también entonces es volver a la
inteligencia del cuerpo que pienso que
hemos puesto de lado bastante y también
por el movimiento yo pienso que el
movimiento nos puede unir porque somos
todos los cuerpos en movimiento
eso es universal
donde nacido el color de mi piel mi
género no importa todo eso hace parte de
lo que de lo que soy y soy un cuerpo en
movimiento
[Música]
estoy aquí entre vosotros en carne y
hueso el gran vals humano nos tocamos no
nos tocamos el espacio que dejó lo
llenará otro
aprendí a escuchar los cuerpos que me
rodean si una imagen vale en mil
palabras
un gesto cual el doble
[Música]
colocar un nuevo el aparejo se sentaron
a lo largo de la nave y ahí está la
dirigía el viento y el piloto
durante todo el día estuvieron
extendidas las velas de su viaje a
través de la imagen
navegaron tanto de día como de noche
durante seis días ya séptimo llegaron a
la escarpada ciudadela
cuando llegaron a su excelente puerto
los rodea por todas partes roca
escarpada y en su boca sobresalen dos
acantilados uno frente a otro por lo que
la entrada es estrecha
todos amarraron dentro de sus curvadas
naves y éstas quedaron atadas muy juntas
dentro del puerto
él ha llegado aquí como un desdichado
después de andar errante y ahora es
preciso atenderle
que todos los huéspedes y mendigos
proceden de un mismo sitio y para ellos
una vida pequeña es querida vamos darle
de comer y de beber y lavado en el río
donde haya un abrigo contra el viento
así que anduvo esté a la deriva durante
dos noches y dos días por las sólidas
olas y muchas veces su corazón presintió
la muerte
cuando estaba tal distancia que se le
habría oído a licitar sintió el
estrépito del mar en las rocas grandes
son las rugían estrepitosamente al
romperse con estruendo contra tierra
civil entonces se cubría de espuma
marina pues no había puertos refugios de
las naves ni ensenadas sino acantilados
rocas y escollos
[Música]
frente al vaivén del dolor la humanidad
busca un par de brazos para acunar la
la comunión de los cuerpos el sacrificio
escenificado la muerte es mucho más
bella los pies en el agua todo lo que ha
naufragado lleva una historia si miro a
lo lejos bastante tiempo la belleza
acabará por surgir
[Música]